now this whole notes slogans of messina
tango and cash
when it comes to professional
relationships who gets top billing is
quite important
glad the white house has got it down
a harris administration together with
joe biden
as the president of the united states
harris pride administration is going to
relaunch that effort
president-elect harris took it took hers
today for the same reason
president harris and i took a virtual
tour of a vaccination center in arizona
it's a little confusing right now a leak
memo indicates white house communication
staffers
should reportedly refer to joe and
kamala as biden harris administration
in official public communications
instead of biden administration
has been done in previous white houses
fox news has requested comment from the
white house about the change
have not heard back joining us now is
someone who spent time at the white
house
george w bush's white house who had a
running mate named dick
cheney but he was not at all the
letterhead ari fleischer now joins us
ari there's 15
executive departments it's all switched
now
to biden harris do you read anything
into this
well walter cronkite let me let me tell
you my take on this
is either two one of two things either
joe biden is being incredibly gracious
and just wants to extend the rubric of
the administration to his vice president
or it's a real sign and it could be both
that joe biden is definitely a one-term
president
at the age of 82 he has no intention of
running for re-election
and he's paving the way now for his
preferred candidate to succeed him
kamala harris i strongly suspect it's
the latter
much more than the former right now
something else that's going on and it
might be because
the former senator former attorney
general is new to the job but as you
know the military is escorting in and
off
military planes she seems not to be
saluting
uh the marines the army who's never the
military officer there
uh who's greeting her is that a problem
you know i i think it's a mistake by her
i'm not gonna throw the book at her on
this you know i just think it's one of
these things where
if you respect the military if you're
aware of who they are their service to
the country
it's just kind of the thing you
intrinsically automatically do when
somebody salutes you you salute back
now i i will say ronald reagan started
that tradition
ronald reagan was a veteran he was
familiar with being saluted at and
saluting back
she's not and interestingly brian the
vice president is not in the military
chain of command
so you know when somebody salutes the
president that's the chain of command
even though he's not in a uniform gotcha
vice president is not even in a uniform
and is not in the military chain of
command it's the president to the
secretary of defense
and down from there but still the point
remains the same it's just good manners
absolutely you should respect the
military when they salute salute back
and i'm also
respecting the fact that there's a
measure moving through the house and
into the senate now hr one that's gonna
federalize elections
we can get into detail but it'll change
elections uh
and it will be election day like we've
never had before more like election
month
as hr1 we're trying to give the voting
to more and more people
according to the democrats isn't ironic
they're trying to take a
uh house seat away in iowa and even two
democrats think
this is out of bounds ironic
yeah what's happening in iowa is an
absolute power grab
and everybody should be alarmed about
what nancy pelosi is trying to engineer
look this is nothing at all like what
happened on january 6.
on january 6 some republicans not all
some republicans
voted to disallow the election of biden
it would not have resulted in putting in
donald trump it just would have sold
confusion
here this is an internal coup what
they're trying to do is throw out
the incumbent republican and replace her
with
a different democrat that is a total
difference from january 6.
and it's an abuse of power if the house
goes through with this i think there's
going to be hell to pay there's going to
be such a rebellion going on in the
house
and if i'm kevin mccarthy whoever wins
by the narrowest margin by the democrats
when he's speaker
miller meeks won the election she got
sworn in she's sitting
rita hart they say well she wants
election she didn't go to iowa she's
actually going
to the federal government to get her
seat back and even democrats are upset
by it
and i remember this happened something
similar happened in the 80s with newt
gingrich when he was a minority member
and it helped him become
speaker of the house it's just
unbelievable what's
what's happening now do you expect hr1
to
actually get green light in a simple
majority
you know i can't see it passing in the
senate you know it's public financing
campaigns which taxpayers have always
objected to why should my money go to
pay for nancy pelosi why should democrat
money
go to pay for marjorie taylor green you
got it i don't think it will pass the
senate
here's harry fleischer thanks so much i
appreciate you closing the show with me